m
mais c'est un trait de lumière s'il vous
plaît
quand vous voulez
comment définir la mémoire
que nous le voulions ou non que nous
sachions non nous sommes responsables de
ce qu'ils nous unir à demain si mal
[Musique]
nous sommes fait de ce qui nous a
précédés vos papiers et pour partie nous
engageons l'avenir
pour emma 4 comme ça
je supporte pas ce que dira par exemple
[Musique]
comment ne pas être conscients de la
nécessité de nous unir pour nous épauler
les uns les autres et résister ainsi
[Musique]
un tour autour du totalitarisme
il faut rester ensemble rien ne doit
nous séparer
c'est plus la passion revu
[Musique]
l'espoir je félicite madame veil pour
son élection c'est en europe que je le
place
l'europe qui a surmonté la haine et la
barbarie votre travail madame veil la
vocation ce n'est pas un travail c'est
une vocation
afin de mettre le bordel faut partir j'y
reste
vous ne faites pas pas
j'avais ton âge
tous les jours je vois mon
[Musique]
ma force
et mon modèle
tous mes combats c'était
horaires
[Musique]